but i was going to say it is monday
uh we want to watch
dana's most recent [ __ ] friday yeah
just to start off the week yeah
or no i guess this would be to end their
week let's not talk about the meta
everyone
it's thursday night or friday morning
let's just kick things off of the
[ __ ] friday we've been on a roll with
that so let's do it
let it rip sticks
flour i i love that he teaches you how
to make it yeah
white sesame seed
black sesame seed smells like bird food
you're gonna take them put them in the
fryer for four minutes at 200 degrees
celsius that's looking good and then you
eat them right out of the fryer
some dried fig
and some green [ __ ]
did he say some green [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay
oh crazy
and i like it thumbs up
there it is the grease edition i got in
trouble for not nailing the kingpin
reference i guess kingpin is
where it was kingpin from
spiderman yeah i say it's from batman i
saw that yeah people were freaking the
[ __ ] marvel definitely ruin people
saturdays with that uh marvel community
yeah i don't even know if it's marvel
seeing already getting it messed up
they're already saying like i got like
straight up death threats did you
actually yeah like you better correct
that on the next episode we're gonna
kill your entire family and your family
we're gonna call kingpin to kill your
entire family down your house yeah so
actually my entire family is at the
basement of this boat right now
because you know maritime laws right you
can't do [ __ ] about it right that's true
you know
what's up it's [ __ ] friday i'm out
here in international waters
he's like
i didn't tell you this
i don't like walnuts he just grabs her
by the neck and throws her over the side
she just says oh no
[Laughter]
i didn't tell you this but
i don't like walnuts luckily i'm too
[ __ ] up to even taste anything right
now
[Laughter]
we're in international waters i just did
five shots of howler head and two lines
of ketamine
and we're gonna kill valentina
folks you've been asking for a long time
i'm gonna kill a woman
for [ __ ]
jesus
friday
jesus [ __ ] christ dude
you guys have been asking for a long
time
i'm going straight to hell dude
i'm gonna kill someone's daughter
for [ __ ] friday
maritime
laws oh man
we're going to kill one underperforming
staff today
you guys have been asking for a long
time we're going to drown someone from
the staff today [ __ ] friday we're
going to make an example out of one of
our staff
we're going to pour hot oil on his neck
we're going to deep fry stephen the
intern
we're gonna deep fry steven and eat them
jesus looks like a firecracker went off
on his face
not a fan actually
[Laughter]
steven tastes like dog food not a fan
nice
oh my god
so so in honor of that that's demented
dana white
no dude devilish dana white
we caught steven stealing out of the
freezer
so we're gonna embellish this gluttony a
little bit and feed him deviled eggs
until he [ __ ] explodes
beat up
stephen i don't want any say it say it
say it
it's [ __ ] friday it's [ __ ] wrong
it sure is stephen
a boar on the floor born on the board
there are no
rules get on the floor
no that's a succession reference that is
an elitist thing if you have hbo max by
the way season three is coming out i
cannot wait oh you know what i started
watching hold on before we get into that
we have our own [ __ ] friday that we
want to do yeah we don't know what we're
going to have yeah is surprising of us
with something yeah it's monday today so
it's but it's that's what i'm saying
it's thursday night probably midnight it
is probably people so it is [ __ ] fun
it is [ __ ] friday [ __ ] it's friday
yeah yeah
well in space too it's weird like in 10
minutes it will be friday yeah so yeah
it's just a strange
thing up here
oh so we're gonna eat something right
now candace can we get that
um can we get that [ __ ] friday in
being now
oh yeah
there we go damn what do we got what do
we got here candace let us know
so i'll let y'all know um
they are two dessert items one is a
sushi crepe
or crepe and one is
called a bash burger it has a burger
covered in chocolate
with fruit inside
oh that actually looks [ __ ] up
well i hate that my
my [ __ ] reflux is gonna fire up if i
even
you have to have a little piece of it
yeah a little something just a small
what's with this
well yeah i'll i'll trade you let me
let me eat one of these first was that
is that actually a fish in it no no no
it's just
so
caramelized fish it's toro with caramel
sauce
that's bluefin tuna with white vanilla
sprinkled on top
so this is a dessert crepe you said yes
and it has a cookie butter
that's [ __ ] up actually like in a good
way
i'm a fan
i didn't tell you this luke
but i don't like dessert
[Laughter]
well then hit him with the hot oil well
then this series is gonna suck for you
this looks disgusting
who would ever order this what is this
supposed to be like a brunch item yeah i
don't know this is so stupid i think it
is a dessert item
who would get this for dessert yeah you
wouldn't want that after anything like
this
i don't want that wait it looks better
in the photos what
is that a pancake what is that
chuck should pretty good
all right let me get a piece of this
thing
you know what
that's a lot better than i thought it
would be i was trying to cut a piece but
[ __ ] it it's friday
yeah eat that right in the mic
right in there
[ __ ] is this we're [ __ ] up your
friday with these mouth noises
that's good right the cereal in there is
good what is covering this
it is uh
kinder bueno white chocolate and cookie
butter
do you like it
yeah
yeah i do
all right the end all right we did it
yeah
everyone's gonna be listening like wow
nobody likes something wow yeah exactly
holy [ __ ] they really did it oh my god
candice you did it it must be that good
he's not complaining oh my god
we're still gonna kill luke though yeah
who's gonna burn them with hot oil
it's [ __ ] friday we're gonna kill our
producer